m
youtube jean-claude zen is once
again the blitz and cm2 videos state of
the union draws a U-turn tropics
nazim of asthma insecurity and the fame
Monster of cause of AIDS wendat 10th
place with an anomaly rate a
driller in france
then bought the daughter of the community andy
foliot nice as a critical assistant
vis à vis before being trained by justin
young tak filiform women lice
model or friends family over the
changes in frankreich millions
derek contact very simple and  classy
late match but chronic räikkönen or
federations mendy hugues brian downpours
the great clint venus and love you
what you curb meals nor hurt in the face of
buyers
justin i go to day of a sinister
europa corp by a series ally pts
i handle  generation 19th vaccine show off
this organization never delay
banega narration deep in pharma
creek shirts faced steve
cano evil strain of asia this normal case
except on what he wishes to do
i  nscribe gewerc wave of africa in
europe and in hitman abstraction
goods routed to the slot
went because jamal or free candidate
below kraft bal
manna screens is what soberly tells us
special taste in my foundation second wave
air canada european center  towards gap
for mrs amos son in this field of
services in france in europe and has sunk
billions via meetings of a
workbook containing your hands and
wonders to douzat of the atv just
green overall idea every sentence at the
intervals on shaft  nîmes
continue young people hang out at 3 my therapy
using high drops they
also pictured at the nationaltraat holland pigeon shooting center
and an address
what a mission susan a devotee kraft bing
the interval between is a
league 1 niche chaining american dreamz towards
an area of ​​far east alinghi
gold these mines did not see it schaffhausen in
europe and i will allow you a
united inspector even if a roma  nce
valdi mark sonia 1.1026 nano itx
secondary language of the isle of man
finished landmarks northrend european before mr
hyde at this boom in his
toulouse ranks iron mittal dnvsf dot
global joke or tons compared young
through a drunk man  when justin
what are you looking for
10/10/2010 la box europe we innovate
cabaret a single assembly line mr
obama towards all dirar and rats
the thomas chardin family national irish
bender sharpening was a diaphragm
between the  'ex prime minister will do as
I said he's a beast a parliament
on the side of the roads
legalize the model association when
the current courts serious
sexual crimes direct your steps
marc homosexuals free libya gaddafi
of the blues will only be done on  scene of the
crime
a franck adds bruce faire during
our information added dassier
operative thanks to their pack towards europe
affair leaves viso and like viso europa
but live I am sick planner  s
relating to the price grid in
three wires of this individual price half a
head in the arabic language by 12
but i do not want will also note in the
choice of luxembourg that the vault 10 10
which frustrates a base and cats to the arv
that our monarchs of  Friday r that's
normal if the normal age with as long as it
's hot as a hot in albi in
match
julia committed Monday in prague this
mormon asks museveni xvi sendas european tests
however this continent goes to those who
m  like actors in america and
hazelnuts an ireland a pleasant to
winter sports skill of a firm frau
to instruct european as at the level of
nine golden face these individuals minister
uses the banana vox total bet or a
college to his  kiss now from florida
does not increase the leap to the social network
gold an obvious lack before by the
flash lite terrorism towards terrorism and
the influx a girl anne radical what
will extremist executives say
group has obviously us so
ext  even a celebration of the opposing world in
his stiff neck
vick a receives a pass and a problem
will be your strategy
micheline especially the fact of having remained
waltz in the group adheres bastos cabaye
already sixteen other matches kennel of the dog
managed offensive makes 10 europa gr
frag richetin  visit and where a
visionary woman at c919
it's a crisis is behind cameron
knowles das maistre d'europeans union
below a vague staff in europe with
the opposite of nice johan face and a
shape america dresses to the test a  a
son falcon last of the same i am
rom soft national family ziriglo nam
which turns up was of low
das neves title euros per horse
steegmans under the terrace where the magma
the kazakh parliament it means chipote
germany possible national fire looks
are flavenot volumes of oil
but this mandate April 6 jihan bring in to
the church near castres after want
to stop doing in der mansion but
dan dah the word this via bus are
obviously  clone ment are stolen
while i put in this village
is down in europe our turn we
concrete towards the crowd his arms towards
a certain that i will bring walking
2/3 of the faces in europe
cloud evolution for jobboom  green has kindly
changed your firm form but europe or
not it enlightens had not braved europe 1 the
ferryman europa the basic weapons in
matter by dividing it the total of the
foams at 4 euros per week during
his vacation
rec 2 euros goes from becoming a  problem
to previous years militarized from
9:30 was furthermore it suits gaza or
not guy talpaert islamists in response to
steenvoorde grail 80 communities and
deutsch hortefeux der veer massive aspis
latin said that a tourist lies to me
under the vaults
tomana generation other  makes
refourguer standards active the mouths tn with
loeb in finland fi the brand table
as must consult the inevitable
east in this friday I'm up to and 90
of business trans  continent or a
smartphone or a tablet of aspirin
summit between the fire Sunday in front
of an African continent it has an
antenna questions about my name it
speaks to us in optis in continent to
deny any scrap in africa it  going to
say
I'm talking to you about betting europe xxl
and talks set dancing anguish this
taste for diagnosis to blacks give up 10
mpx gay at this level at the means
of children come williams take that means
of what if i want is claim to should
not block youtube and my daughter goisses
dati life floats the opinionway is
hired city notes from 8 to 12 years old
both had everything in the world which is
the expression of a to lift me up a
week and the hes so many  have all already
what the said want to be a fan cannot
be not give in to the british food unida
d'espionage
à dofas data base of mind is to the next
recycling
i am not  pas n youtube was born at
your house you film witch mountain at
combating laetitia hello mr
president settle down thank you welcome
to my living room
yes the one in my life must know that
it is an artificial living room but you have
taken an influence on them
bring you a lot closer and it's very well
done I wanted to thank you already 2
me for receiving me and allowing me
to meet you
I am really honored really delighted
because you are at the head of the
highest authority in europe and that  is a
wonderful opportunity for me to be able
to ask you the questions of my
community and to be able to represent the
young people of Europe the young French people so
thank you very much for welcoming me
so I had a first question
many young Europeans are very
sensitive to the  ecology and the effects of
chemicals on our health and
on my youtube channel, for example, I
talk a lot about all these subjects
because I'm going to be a mother one day and
the environment in which she will grow up
my children is very important a point
which is important for me is the
question of endocrine disruptors
normally in particular sorry because
I cannot manage to be a mother and I
am not convinced that this  is not
bound by the way on this famous
question of endocrine disruptors
the European Commission has only
postponed the ban for two and a half years
and that also reminds me of
the question of the roundup which is
at the origin of many camps of
many cancers of people who are
exposed and who also couldn't been who
didn't he who wasn't forcibly banned
I come to feel
that perhaps the role of the
commission would have been  finally to
dangle us with bans which do
not happen and which perhaps gives
multinationals time to continue to earn a
lot of money and see you Friday
and chemical products which are
hurting us suddenly the question I would like  s
to ask you sir length is
how to do not to be worried
and how could you
reassure me but we are working on these
subjects and we are working on these subjects
there are in the scientific world
different appreciations on the
products of which you speak  I am
more on the side of those finally I
would not say of those who are afraid okay
but of those who wonder and
sometimes I ask myself the question if the
scientific opinions which are published and which
they have distributed to the
whole planet are free from the influences of the
big producer groups and so the
commission is working on this subject and
we do not take it lightly it
's okay subject so I'm how to say
impressed by the
problem okay thank you so my second
question  is the next your
predecessor in the post of the
european commission mr barroso joined
that summer goldman sachs and i was
personally challenged by this choice
because i  asked myself the question
as a citizen, when he
had his role as president, was he
not complacent, perhaps with his future
employer, or is it that now that he
holds a position in a private bank,
he does not  did not arrive with
state secrets in his pockets for example but
it is doubt there are not very important
because they are that my doubts
concerning many others also
here but in any case settled it s
were  mine, but
I don't think it's the most important thing,
and regarding this appointment you
said in the evening newspaper that
we had no problem with him
working in a private bank
insofar as he had respected  the
18-month deadlines which are imposed by European law
so that I also understand that but
you added that the fact that they
work for this bank where you
pose a problem
and suddenly I was surprised I was
a little bit lost because  e i did
n't understand very well and i was
wondering why this
bank in particular poses a problem
i don't understand very well finally
yes first of all i think that rayman
gypsy has a club foot m he's a friend
he took  the decision to join the
group as sex after an imposed deadline
while others count
as demanding driving course does not exist in
any of our member states not even in
the country you know best and
therefore france which he respected  the
rules yes so I don't see a
big problem in the fact that he does
n't solve the finance sector others have
done it besides his tablet you
want I don't know if a guy leaves a
big company you become  minister
nobody asks questions as
if the one who was in the solidly
paid service of a large firm a large
company of a large bank
would not carry in his new function
all the knowledge and all the reflexes
q  that we were able to acquire by working in
the private sector there we never ask ourselves
questions but if a politician
leaves the political scene to join
the private sphere which is
something normal in the United States where there is
a mixture between  public post is on
a private path everyone is asking
questions
what did I say I said I
repeat to myself a lot of problems that they take
a job in a
private bank in Kassala because
goldman sachs  was one of those sets
that contributed to the
knowing not knowing to the emergence of a
huge financial and economic crisis in
the years 2007 2008 of the terminals v and
so I arise education on the identity
of the port to which it
goes okay okay thank you to my next
question is the following
in recent months we have heard a lot
about the revelations of the
whistleblower antoine delcourt deltour and in
particular us in france and it has been
shown in particular that luxem  bourg has
allowed in the greatest secrecy to
multinationals like mcdonald's or
like pepsi to repatriate all their
profits made in the feet of rock
and to pay in the end only one percent
of tax
me when I prepared this interview
j  I was amazed because my husband has a
small business and pays him 33
% taxes and suddenly the difference between
the two seemed huge but
fortunately you said that your
commission would do what is necessary
to make this social
injustice a  priority and suddenly I
was relieved but the question I
then asked myself was and it
is perhaps a very naive question is
that ultimately you are really in the
best position to be able to put an end to
this social injustice  because alas
it's nothing personal and it's
not an attack at all but I was wondering
confided quality never have life
really not but the question I
was asking myself confided in someone who  has
been  minister of finance for 18 years
of the largest tax haven in europe
the mission to fight against tax
evasion is what it would be not
ultimately a little bit like appointed
chief of police a bank robber
yes finally it is often said that
robbers and  the poachers are
constituted in our services of the
emerging pole elements but let's forget that
you relate to the country which is mine
good I am no longer responsible with a
superficial look which translates quite well the
French condescension when it
looks
when the French look at the
others in  europe
each country is the tax haven of its
veil
are you sure and certain
that what was called the texts
therefore underlines the arrangements between
friends nistration until the companies
did not take place in france I am
certain  you're welcome finally that's why
I'm here and you will know great
pleasure finally I tell you in after
people present that what you will
discover  laugh will not make you
happy okay but regardless of that
i was and i remain convinced that in
europe we need a minimum
how to say
normality companies have to pay their
taxes or where they make their
profits and to  what does the
heart committee that i chair
relate to and we take this very seriously as
the decision on apple in ireland proved
and other decisions without consideration
of peli of flags and people will
intervene during the weeks
of
close agreement but it's me I've never
taken a decision on the
individual taxation of a company on
Luxembourg holidays it's the fed in
saved them since al which does not prevent us from
being able to s  talk with the
big foreign investors who
wanted to settle in luxembourg all the
first on all the sites and finance
receives the big leaders of the big
international groups
but there has never been how to say
an influence  ur the modalities the
details of the particular taxation
of a sole proprietorship I
would like all those who have helped the
Prime Minister of Finance
in their country to be able to say the same I
agree thank you very much for his
explanations suddenly I see a little bit  clearer
and I am doing what you invited me
to react and we are of course looking with
great pleasure at
my next question it is a question
that has been asked to me a lot by my
community
you know me I have a channel
youtube where I talk a lot about ecology
and it's a question about
how lobbies influence European laws
and in my
previous question in the first question I
want to explain to you that I was talking
about lobbies in fact in the organic sector
but  Internet users have insisted a lot
on the tiny influence of lobbies
in all other areas and he does not
remind me, for example, that
citizens who elect deputies
elect deputies who cannot  I can't vote for
laws and I'm surprised, it's that in
Brussels there are between 20,000 and 30,000
lobbyists and the industry who
employ them spend millions of euros
to gain influence suddenly I
think for example  to the case of philip
morris who employs 160
full-time people and who gives them an envelope of
1.5 million euros to organize
dinners and events and
finally I think I find that these efforts are
not in vain because ultimately it
bears fruit
and while searching I
also got closer to the pharmaceutical industry and
I realized that through
the various lobbies your committee
met, for example between 2014 and
2015 up to twice a week,
lobbyists and I  I tell myself that it
necessarily creates a working relationship that
is held and above all that is maintained
by people
and where I'm coming from is that
I am president of a small
association in France, an association
humanita  ire and an association related to
organic and I wonder for example how to
imagine that associations of
citizens like me for example can
have the same budget and can have
the same opportunities as
companies and that brings me to the question
that I  wanted to ask you is that in the
end I find it hard to believe that
the European Union can be the guarantor
of the general interest of the people rather
than the interest of companies
insofar as I have the impression that  they
walk hand in hand a little bit
and what I wanted to ask you
is do you think that the European Union
is ultimately the guarantor of men, therefore
of human beings or rather of
companies, what is your feeling on
this subject?  In general, we
cannot systematically oppose the
two citizens, consumers
and large pharmaceutical groups or
others, but there is some truth in your
question. First of all, the MEP
passed the law passed the law with you.  z says we are
not going to law they vote government laws
and as soon as I take office of which you
are the start
the mandate of the of the
current commission to establish a
transparency register so all the lobbyists
you said there the  commission received
between 2014-2015 joy twice a
week i don't have guy how
come you know
and because we publish yes
contact us and i made sure
all winds the president of the  commission
and vice-president the commercial
directors general finally all the
services must indicate to the general
public
which are the lobbies which they received
in their office or in a tavern the
lower rooms so that one knows who has
it is to make influential on  that she
draws me I am not opposed in
principle to lobbying if lobbying
is a participation is more decision
that represents the interests of big
business or consumer organizations
we also receive
engaging monu  mental
it is by the European commission which
gives their budget to the lobbies its health
on the other hand we support ourselves
financially from other
more virtuous circles of influence like
the storms have large drummers and
eauze so for me the essential is that
the  Europeans know who saw who on
block by block subject this is what we reported to
ourselves in my
imagination as citizens and young
women so that means that basically we
have lobbyists who have thousands
of euros for  to be able to do their
lobbying work and the answer that we
finally give is to tell them well if you
want you can register in a
notebook to declare that you are a
lobbyist no mom and I I receive
let's say a big banker I do it
know and therefore those who observe me
can verify whether or not the point
of view the always known tag of this
great pomp or of a large
company could have produced affects as to the
content of the decisions which are those of
the commission and the guts then came
from the urban facing then I am
only full transparency moreover
I am not enough the favorite of these
circles there okay I tell you that
poor sion you reassure me listen
I you  asked all my questions
and as time is running out I'm going
to thank you for having answered him
for having played the game thank you very much
I would have liked to not sell him but me
but I too would have liked to force
with pleasure but decided that  we
had to interrupt
I think it's time the
commission decides everything it's not
true the others and yes I have
to let my colleague speak who is
just as excited about me at the idea of
meeting you
yes ok thank you very much it's a card see you
soon I hope it's not the
first time with a youtube is this
your first interview yes good will be the
last
good I hope we want to see you very
soon not far  of us
young
casino gives new dress and  at alice's
necessary the quetsches of a probable
except colleter life at destination monday
16 to 20 weeks in a pond nostrum
king kong and shenzhen tokyo
economic contraction of high quality jones said
there was indeed yes said during a
request for records  naughty and blunders
consulted ch
we had the responsibility of social minima that
they go from Sind is ok
flexibility make table sometimes to it
is implemented the strategy of taking
the young chicks to be formed at the pin
takes violent ten dates blind
flexible
sometimes lively
jade binks wanted to lay back on track
avenue university so this week
he is arrested in a
security company which does not hide that you have my
name is joe flacco
the beauport speaker will be our next
film debt or other finally going close
to opening  books my job he
does work not speak to pipe in the
what's eating clues payment thalys
our record was enough for the
classic spec madness kitchen the province is
when m  ême bizarre is endowed with a close
or leaf
be nice of the iep type to realities of
the offensive environment has put it goes from our
imam in public
to those news by clicking from flora by
being moved by a practice in things
we can  yes the progress towards reaching
the evening one goal is not giving he says
9:10 trick piquant district to say yes i
do things or hip hop dj dan brown has
everything from match up and claude monde
there is on his  life was little by little to recreate the
tactic of two destroyed to wash
herriot pin in any case our
technological faith cd4 of wood and that jamal
rhmani is thirsty he affirms annie to the
false doors are possible mata is to
organize transport said to kadam and that this
program  1900 group inc at 22 10 euros
this pine care program with binh
quang binh and systems
once of a bimes system is missed
a gatineau job campaign to be
condemned yes is he beat her and they
collect I am a millionaire luigi this
a nail diva four turbines soft
neck  vert par le dr this scheduled match
we would like to extend program all
apprentice his dreams this gesture this dialogue
is a punk duo to create crop
speak like to go outside the world to be
offers a solid dose match to nice shot
not director mariloup pec having
nibbled at looking to football singer
be a possible battery charge of
future assets can contact it
fills end planetoscope
one way out to bring you to i like it
and while i'm not because of domain this
we to the section is
open domain  yes it is necessary to help him
white witch 2.639 hillman from a back to
move to gaza two years ago date to snow
it is estimated that between have said everything he
according to enough to save a life in a
complicated goblet said what we have to
halfway between as yes to all this beautiful list
continent we should not in verse too
marginal from france he had done everything
like chanel at all costs
the name of my title that Tuesday against
knicks cabaye turn of the question is only
'to me ok that p  as at all of the
two guys we long from cindy is not
worse off weight screw from kayes ayala to
jack wilson president of djoliba in any
case there it is because at the bottom of the
kingdom crisis mass sport and very sweet
evening  laetitia and yoann goucuff
can't get you out of my league